northwest valley right now metro police
are investigating a suspicious death
inside a storage unit joe moeller is
live now near centennial parkway and
durango with the latest from metro
police joe good afternoon
good afternoon john we are just west of
durango on centennial parkway a woman
was found dead in a storage unit here at
the storage facility the sign outside
says it's storage west we'll give you a
look at the investigation it is just
down this driveway on the left hand side
is where that storage unit is a small
unit but police say they were deeming
this suspicious because it was not
locked accidentally
around six monday morning police got a
call from a person who found a dead
woman inside the storage unit police
believe the victim in her 50's was
living in the unit with several other
people it was someone who knew the woman
was living there who called police we
know for a fact that you cannot close
this door and lock her in there without
knowing that she was in there police are
speaking with the person who was renting
that specific unit and they are looking
for the other people who are living here
at some point he says there was a lot of
drug use happening there as well
now back out here live another look at
the investigation there are multiple
police units here for this investigation
spencer did not say how the woman
possibly died the coroner will release
that information he says possibly coming
out tomorrow they are looking again to
talk to those people who are also living
in that unit or looking for anyone with
any information if you know anything
police would like to hear from you or
you can call crime stoppers reporting
live in the northwest valley joe muller
live local now